merci elle a effectivement le voilà une
phobie française livres parus ces
derniers jours
thomas thévenoud à propos de ce livre
c'est quoi c'est une psychothérapie ou
c'est une opération de retour en
politique
non parce que l'opération de retour en
politique d'abord j'ai pas quitter la
politique injuste rester député métier
plus dans la sphère médiatique sur les
plateaux non parce que j'ai considéré
qu'il fallait d'abord m'occupe de
circonscriptions ce que j'ai fait oui il
ya un aspect d'explication et jeudi il
en suivre que j'essaye de creuser à
l'intérieur de moi pour comprendre mais
l'opération de communication politique
savait pas ce que c'était que tous les
gens nous ont dit je voulais d'immersion
on a vu plein de messages sur les
réseaux sociaux
en disant non mais vous lui donnez la
parole parce qu'il veut se refaire une
image se refaire une virginité c'est ça
que vous êtes en train de re de deux
femmes et les gens ils jouent d'ailleurs
on l'a vu dans le sillon de la mémoire
simplement il juge le bonhomme avec ses
qualités ses défauts et en 2017 ça sera
stop ou encore stop ou encore connaissez
l'émission ben si si les gens veulent
encore ça sera bien s'ils veulent plus
et bien jusqu'au de choses c'est comme
ça c'est la vie
et puis ça sera peut-être très bien pour
moi si je suis battu ou au contraire les
gens diront bien il a fait du boulot
donc on lui accorde une deuxième chance
mais finalement ce sont les électeurs
qui m'ont choisi m'ont permis d'aller
justement de sur ce petit manège qui
tourne de plus en plus vite
bombay s'ils veulent plus ils me
retirent leur confiance
ça vous ferait pas peur une campagne
après tout ce qui a été dit sur vous
d'aller affronter des gens non non c'est
un peu ça me fait peur parfois pour ceux
qui m'entourent ceux qui me soutiennent
les soutiens mes amis mes collaborateurs
mon équipe qui restait fidèle autres
familles en pense quoi vous dire toute
ma famille et partager partager parce
que ma mère j'ai la chance d'avoir des
parents jeune mon père habite salornay
dans la circonscription plutôt favorable
à ce qu'il y retourne ma mère un peu
moins voilà
mon épouse partager on en discute
il ya des jours avec et des jours sans
mais ça c'est la vie mais si vous voulez
moi à partir du moment où j'ai gardé mon
mandat ne pas se représenter c'est ce
défilé c'est trop facile
moi je n'ai pas peur des gens je je si
j'avais peur des gens je n'aurais pas
fait ce livre je l'aurais pas appeler
une phobie française
j'assume mes fautes hier que tout le
monde assume j'ai fait des fautes mais
enfin je suis pas les seuls en politique
avoir de fait des fautes
un des fautes morales ou des fautes
politiques certains ont fait des grosses
grosses erreurs politiques pendant ce
quinquennat qu'il les assume
moi je me représente et puis les gens
choisissent on a senti jérôme durain que
je mens sénateurs saône-et-loire qui a
été longtemps premier fédéral du
département dont qui connaît
parfaitement les arcanes de son
département
on le sent un petit peu tendu sur le sur
l'interview parce que la question qui se
pose dans votre département c'est est ce
que le parti socialiste vous n'en n'êtes
plus on va présenter un candidat sur
cette circonscription et qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est ce que vous pensez vous
pensez que ce serait normal puisque vous
ne faites plus partie du parti
socialiste
vous pensez qu'en réalité vous défendez
toujours leurs idées que donc c'est
logique de ne pas vous mettre quelques
quelqu'un en face de vous comprends que
le parti socialiste soit un peu dans une
situation d'inconfort bon mais moi
toujours de gauche c'est pas changé je
suis pas passé à droite parce que je
paye mes impôts en temps et en heure bon
je suis un député de gauche qui reste de
gauche c'est à dire convaincus que la
gauche peut apporter de l'espoir à ce
pays notamment la jeunesse de ce pays
voilà on en parle beaucoup de la
jeunesse en ce moment mais je suis libre
je suis libre et je ne veux plus
d'étiquette on en a suffisamment mis sur
le crâne pour pas en avoir une
supplémentaire le ps fera bien ce qui
veux moi et c'est extrêmement mal à ce
que vous faites ce serait une bonne idée
par est étiqueté ps aux prochaines
législatives puisque c'est la bérézina
qui s'annonce je ne sais pas si c'est
malin je voulais dit tout à l'heure si
je pouvais revenir en arrière je
reviendrai en arrêt mais on va pas me
demander maintenant moins d'appliquer à
la lettre toutes les directives de
solférino alors que j'ai été viré du
jour au lendemain comme un malpropre
donc on m'a viré j'ai retrouvé une forme
de liberté ça veut dire qu'il ya des
choses que je n'accepte pas j'ai voté
contre la loi sur le renseignement
j'ai voté contre la déchéance je pense
que la loi et le comme ris encore
beaucoup de boulot à faire sirugue
christophe sirugue le député de chalon
ont fait un travail remarquable je veux
le dire la sur votre antenne il essaye
de faire atterrir cette loi pour qu'elle
soit quand même un peu plus compatible
avec le droit des salariés
j'ai rencontré la cgt encore jeudi il ya
encore du boulot d'ailleurs il explique
christophe sirugue bon mais on va pas me
demander de tout voter et d'être un
godillot après ce que ce que j'ai subi
je suis de gauche et je suis libre vous
avez dit grosse faute
est-ce que de votre point de vue il est
raté ce quinquennat
non il ya des choses bien il ya des
choses qui ont été faites tomber
moi je pense qu'il ya la question du
quand la jeunesse est dans la rue avec
un gouvernement de gauche
et quand on a fait de la jeunesse la
priorité du quinquennat quand on a fait
de la jeunesse priorités du quinquennat
je pense qu'il ya deux problèmes en
effet la genèse et le chômage des jeunes
ça renvoie la sempiternelle question de
la courbe du chômage
et il ya la question européenne le
président de la république françois
hollande a été élu pour changer l'europe
pour réorienter la politique européenne
or moi je constate que le mécanisme cinq
ans après encore gagner donc je je je
pense que en matière européenne
on n'a pas assez changé les choses voilà
une europe plus sociale une europe où
l'harmonisation fiscale et sociale faire
en sorte que on se fait pas concurrence
les uns et les autres une europe qui se
protège qui protège son appareil
productif et industriel des questions
que mon bon ami dans le coeur du débat
n'est que vous anticipez ce que je vais
vous dire on vous entendra l'impression
d'entendre arnaud montebourg non parce
que macron dit la même chose
regardez ce que dit macron macron dit
des choses sur le le redressement
productif alors il emploie pas
l'expression de montebourg parce que le
redressement productif
c'est presque une marque déposée par
arnaud montebourg mais macron dit des
choses qui vont dans le même sens et
tout ça c'est des ce sont des questions
européennes qui se joue à l'échelle
européenne
donc moi ce que je regrette c'est qu'on
n'est pas renverser la table un certain
moment en matière européenne
vous suivrez emmanuel macron ça vous
intéresse cette nuisance ou presque y
ait un certain nombre d'ailleurs de
députés qui d'ores et déjà on le sait
pas mais sont dans l'organigramme
derrière nous
maquereau mariné je suivre évidemment
les débats la primaire je pense qu'il y
aura une primaire à gauche et que de
fait elle s'imposera même au président
de la république et la présidentielle
évidemment j'aurais des préférences et
je les exprime rivoire non mais je vais
assumer
your are de montebourg à ce prix mais
s'il ya une primaire moi je souhaite
qu'il faut agrandir mais je suis pas son
porte parole
je ne vous étiez à frangy 20 jours où
tout a explosé c'est d'ailleurs un peu à
côté de ça vous vous être trop de
ministres derrière ben non seulement
j'étais à frangy mais j'étais entre
arnaud montebourg et benoît bon je
raconte dans un livre et je sens que les
choses basculent au cours de
l'après-midi de frangy parce que il
reçoit des sms de matignon et ils
sentent eux-mêmes que le sol est en
train de se dérober mais c'est aussi une
une façon pour arnaud montebourg que je
connais très bien de réinventer sa vie
lui aussi est en train de réinventer sa
vie voyez qu'on se pose tous des
questions à certains moments quand on
est dans la politique
et quand on a la lucidité et la
conscience qu'il faut prendre un peu de
distance
une phrase du livre c'est la dernière on
avait envie de vous demander ce qu'elle
veut dire
le livre se termine par rien ne presse
vraiment ça veut dire qu'on doit le
comprendre comment ça veut dire que on
n'est pas obligé de remonter sur le
manège comme un fou et de repartir comme
en 40
voilà rien ne presse vraiment moi
j'avais un problème de retard un
problème avec le temps le temps qui me
qui allait trop vite dans ma vie qui me
faisait oublier un certain nombre de mes
obligations
rien ne presse vraiment ça veut dire que
on n'est pas obligé de deux fois zir ce
qu'on va faire pour les 10 années qui
viennent la vie c'est aussi ça c'est
elle est belle parce qu'elle est
incertaine elle est pleine
d'incertitudes et pour la première fois
de ma vie je ne sais pas ce que je vais
devenir en 2017 et ça me rend presque
heureux si vous n'êtes pas élu au
législatif de 2017 le thomas thévenoud
de la décennie suivante s'imagine comme
un rejet j'ai quelques idées sur
quelques idées allez vous voulez que je
voudrais impôts taxes c'est pareil
montebourg nous a dit ian clarke et il
ya quelques mois j'étais avec ma famille
à madrid et dans la capitale espagnole
il
a eu aucune épicerie fine de produits
français non mais vous riez mais
j'allais chez des amis espagnols et je
voulais leur offrir une bouteille de
bourgogne alors impossible j'ai appris
que au moment des fêtes c'est
l'ambassade de france qui ouvre un
comptoir pour foie gras champagne
ben voilà et puisque et à madrid
avec évidemment des vins de bourgogne
des packs du bourgogne un basque avant
des vins de bourgogne et fromages de
chèvre du mâconnais à des choses simples
et vous préféreriez être thomas
thévenoud députés en 2017
j'en sais rien je suis je sais pas ce
que je gère la politique c'est toujours
une passion et je me bats tous les jours
c'est ce que m'a racontée dans le livre
vous faisait des petits enfants faisait
des photos de françois mitterrand lors
de ses déplacements et donc grandir avec
la politique révéle politique et
finalement m'est tombé à travers la
politique ça fait encore aimer la
politique il ya un ailleurs si j'ai
écrit ce livre est que j'ai écrits du
début jusqu'à la fin
c'est pour explorer un ailleurs c'est la
première fois que j'écris un livre c'est
pas facile d'écrire il faut monter des
chapélies trouver un rythme une voix un
ton voilà c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
faire
j'ai déjà exploré un monde que je ne
connaissais pas
l'écriture et ça m'a fait du bien parce
que seulement parce que j'ai creusé en
moi même mais aussi parce que j'ai
appris des choses
comment monter un récit comment essayer
de tenir le lecteur jusqu'au bout lui
faire comprendre les choses et à la fin
ce qu'il faut savoir finir un livre j'ai
voulu que la fin soit incertaine
indécise
à l'image de la vie que j'ai aujourd'hui
vous parlez de vos filles dans le livre
il ya une scène très drôle il faut dire
ouais se demande si vous pourriez pas
avoir une coupe parce que vous êtes ce
n'était le fanal plus brefs
aujourd'hui elles ont grandi depuis
quand même bon quel regard elles portent
là dessus elles ont grandi nous on a
grandi aussi avec moi aussi j'ai grandi
à travers 7 7
cette épreuve lll savent ce que le nom
de thévenoud
porte porte en lui les filles thévenoud
comme elles se font appeler recon mais
voilà je crois que sont pas si je peux
le dire mais je pense qu'elles sont
fiers aussi d'être excités venu comme
vous dites en tout cas j'espère il ya un
jour où elles vont en garder un il ya un
jour où quand je vais leur rappeler
leurs obligations
quand elles seront à dos j'imagine qu'il
y en a une des deux jeux c'est même déjà
peut-être laquelle qui va me dire écoute
pas pas franchement t'as déconner elle
aura ce livre pour essayer de comprendre
avait toujours le même ami non j'ai
changé il y avait quelques uns que j'ai
gardées et d'autres qui sont apparus
pilotes étaient des gentils sont je
disais il ya des gens qui sont en dehors
du cercle politique qui sont venus me
rencontrer et qui m'ont adressé des
messages d'amitié j'ai plein d'amis dans
la circonscription qui sont restés là
recchi qui s'expriment pas et mais dix
sont toujours là s'ils sont toujours là
parce qu'ils savent que voilà en tant
que député je fais mon boulot donc et
nière politique c'est pas toujours là on
prend quel regard vous portez sur le
thomas thévenoud d'avant vous y pensez
souvent ce livre vous à pernand de je
vous le disais tout à l'heure on il ya
des gens qui nous ont appelés au ki moon
nous ont dit mes vestes aux maths et
nous avons il était dur il était en gros
au crédit mais c'est dire que pour lui
ce qui lui arrive et quoi d'une certaine
manière pas et j'étais un type très
ambitieux à la fois très ambitieux très
énergie en même temps je faisais du
boulot quand même un jeu j'étais actif
c'est aussi pour ça que j'ai été pris au
gouvernement ne s'est pas complètement
par hasard hein c'est aussi parce que
j'avais marqué mon arrivée mais ce
thomas thévenoud là il a disparu il a
été éjectée du manège donc il est à la
fois en moi il y en a un autre qui est
en train de naître
ce qui est drôle c'est un autre député
bourguignon c'est laurent grandguillaume
qui fait avec les tas de films dont il
aurait eu de suite vous parlez souvent
oui bien sûr on se parle souvent parce
que je connais un peu le sujet des taxis
et laurent est un type formidable ça
c'est un très très bon député de cette
génération pour chuté parfois face à une
enveloppe non j'ouvre mes enveloppe et
je paie mes factures
on vous a reproché quelques jours pas
voir courir mais j'ai reçues il j'ai
reçu la facture mardi matin je les
payais mardi à midi et moi j'accuse
jeudi on a cru bon envoyer la facture en
parallèle aux canards ans chez moi ville
canard enchaîné veut fouiller les
poubelles de la maison il n'y a pas de
problème si même il ya un journal du
canard enchaîné qui veut venir à la
maison dormir il ya une place sur le
canapé
il sera le bienvenu on lui fera du thé
et il pourra regarder si on paye les
factures - voilà j'ai changé vous n'avez
plus la pochette noire non la pochette
aristocratie nation et une pochette
noire avec une étoile rouge est dedans
il y avait des enveloppes mais il n'ya
pas que moi vous savez autour autour de
vous vous faites le sondage et les gens
qui m'aident dans des pochettes dans des
boîtes à chaussures
bon ils s'arrangent avec la réalité ça
arrange où ils s'arrangent pas
d'ailleurs avec la réalité mais la
pochette nommé n'existe plus et les
enveloppes sont sont ouverts tous les
matins merci thomas thévenoud il est
revenu sur un plateau d'opinion vous
avez fait beaucoup de bateaux parisiens
on était confirmée à bercy sur un
plateau bourguignon même si il faut le
redire tout le monde n'a pas forcément
apprécié qu'on veuille entendre que vous
aviez à nous dire mais on avait souhaité
le faire tout de même merci à vous
samedi prochain rendez vous ici même
pour un nouveau numéro de la voie est
libre